excellences mesdames et messieurs tout
est
aujourd'hui il ya une lueur sur la mer
noire une lueur d'espoir une lueur de
possibilités une lueur de soulagement
dans un monde qui en a besoin plus que
jamais je tiens à remercier et à
reconnaître toutes les parties prenantes
qui ont permis de rendre ce jour pro
aussi de toros ne vous présentez
redonner le gouvernement de la turquie
votre détermination votre persistance
ont été essentiels ont été instrumental
à chaque étape de ce processus
merci beaucoup
aux représentations de la fédération de
russie et de l'ukraine vous avez
réussi à paver la voie vers une
initiative qui sert à l'intérêt de tous
et ce en surmontant les obstacles vous
permettait d'apporter bien-être à
l'humanité permettre plus tôt gd le
monde a toujours été le moteur de cette
réflexion
le l'accent a été mis sur ce qui est le
plus important pour la population
mondiale il ne fait aucun doute d'une
chose c'est que c'est un accord qui sert
le monde c'est un accord qui permettra
de soulager les pays pauvres près de la
faillite cela permettra d'aider les
personnes proches de la famille de la
famine cela permettra de stabiliser le
prix des denrées alimentaires déjà à des
niveaux très élevés à même avant la
guerre et ce qui représente un petit
cauchemar pour les pays pauvres
l'initiative plus spécifiquement
permettra d'ouvrir
la voie à de grands des
exportations grâce venant de haut grâce
à trois quatre grands ports turcs
le transport des céréales et des
produits alimentaires permettra de
réduire la pression sur les prix est de
réduire également la crise alimentaire
excellences mesdames et messieurs cet
accord n'a pas été facile à obtenir
depuis le début de la guerre j'ai mis en
lumière le fait qu'il n'existe pas de
solution à la crise alimentaire mondiale
sans s'assurer qu'il y ait un accès
complet à aux produits alimentaires
ukrainiens et aux produits alimentaires
et aux engrais russe aujourd'hui nous
avons fait un grand pas en avant pour
atteindre ses objectifs
toutefois le chemin a été long au mois
d'avril
après avoir été reçu par le président
enzo anne j'ai rencontré le président
poutine et le président azzedine ski
afin de présenter un plan proposant des
solutions et nous avons travaillé chaque
jour depuis il a fallu énormément
d'efforts et d'engagement des deux côtés
et des semaines de négociations 24
heures sur 24 l'engagement est
aujourd'hui plus important que jamais
cette initiative doit être totalement
mise en oeuvre pour quoi car le monde a
besoin de cet accord pour lutter contre
cette crise alimentaire mondiale nous
comptons sur le gouvernement de la
turquie pour maintenir son rôle critique
à l'avenir
les nations unies seront au présent nous
sommes
nous sommes présents pourra s'assurer
durée de la réussite de ce succès de cet
accord et nous assurons que les
engagements pris sont respectées je suis
reconnaissant envers les travail des
deux task force des deux groupes de
travail qui ont permis d'avoir une
approche coordonnée martin griffiths le
secrétaire général pour les affaires
humanitaires
et l'organisation internationale des
affaires maritimes se sont concentrés
sur le transport des céréales ukraine
par la mer noire
aujourd'hui nous annonçons la création
d'un centre de coordination conjoint
pourra examiner ou pour s'assurer de la
mise en oeuvre de cette forêt là le gros
groupe de travail dirigé par un martin
griffiths a permis d'assurer un accès
sans contrainte des céréales et des
produits alimentaires venant de russie
un accord a pu être trouvé et
j'encourage les différentes parties
prenantes à faire tous les efforts
nécessaires pour assumer respecter leurs
engagements nous devons faire tous les
efforts possibles pour garantir la paix
c'est un accord sans précédent entre
deux partis participant un conflit un
conflit armé qui existe encore
aujourd'hui des gens meurent encore
chaque jour et les combats font rage au
quotidien cette lueur d'espoir sur la
mer noire briffard aujourd'hui grâce à
l'effort conjoint de nombreuses parties
prenantes en cette période difficile
pour la région et pour le monde que
cette lueur nous guide vers un
allègement des souffrances pour la
population et de une plus grande
stabilité et une plus grande
merci beaucoup monsieur le secrétaire
général